yeah hello I'm this video playing shoe
shittin or something shootin I don't
know let's see one out of three hmm
that's not good oops no not before
please okay so I've got the Slav okay
let's go with this kind of not moving
very precisely sometimes you have
problems with that if you have somehow
changed your you're sitting position
yeah like at the desk maybe I've changed
something that 97 hmm okay do I go for a
classical center or 4G 3i rather do the
classical one with a form maybe plays
Bishop f5 now yes certainly totally
possible okay I wonder wonder if night
g5 is a 1995 e6e for mmm that's it's a
bit bit bit hasty let's just let's just
develop oh I thought that this wouldn't
work so i hears 'if I've aged 6
something funky like that on Wow
what the funny position okay let's see
what happens here
yeah yeah I thought I can take here
because I have the intermediate threat
of taking on g7 but he has g5 which is
kind of crazy but it is some somehow
runnable
very strange stuff antique s65 23 I have
no idea what what to make of this
position yeah yes did with a g5 I guess
we should be three then he moves the
bishop
I didn't think of that at all ah crazy
things
wow I would like to play rook to you one
really really badly but Bishop us on age
five
take
tenda gave five as me TM this is really
awkward
oh I totally misplayed this check sorry
my only hope is that he is one of those
instant movers probably missing wins
hopefully missing wins and now he takes
some time Jay probably see can just take
btooom and play for the material this is
the problem he doesn't have to play for
mates maybe that's would I mean rook to
e3 maybe yeah but he also could have
just taken material right away
say a way to prevent queen bee three
time money and not really
yeah Queen d3 is winning the whole time
but he seems to shoot for something
better
no takes 93 it was nice okay champ white
resigns allowing that if all move looked
looked really bonkers but maybe it was
okay yeah Eve form chair so I probably
have to avoid this
95 is better for Wyatt I mean and it's
really quite obvious but I mean you want
to punish the people for playing weird
stuff like this night bd7 already as a
strange move this shouldn't be any good
relief it's it's just the worst version
of the the main lights laughs so you six
yeah I have to go 95 something like this
one where I have the center i haven't
played a form which is the big
difference to the main line classical
and it is slightly better i play a 3
Bishop e2 and stuff like that but this
this is now leading to a total mess and
which I quickly got outplayed yeah he
saw that Queen txt for that was very
strong of course I mean once you see it
to say how easy but I didn't I didn't
appreciate that matter why yeah I
basically lost now check check yeah
nicely played really nicely played I
have to play that 95 movie 5 is really a
funny that's really funny yeah it's
sometimes funny are they people I mean
he didn't expect that it was just
happening as it as it went along that is
not losing stuff here and exactly age 6
I mean I can go can do this but that's
already yeah that's no good in
comparison i have to go 95
it's much much stronger okay well thanks
for watching